our goal is pretty simple
[Music]
it's harder
you asked me what I do here this is what
I do I find you players and I feel it
this time
I knew the greatest basketball shoe
that's ever been made who's the player
Michael Jordan
we are going to stop that monster no
pressure
I'm an artist instead of a woman who
says really mean things to other women
you were an artist
[Music]
every team has their light and our lane
is real church music I change the music
what it's gonna be great we are
terrified
my boss gave me this power
in return I tend to his needs including
care feeding healing and people to eat
I mean I know this sounds crazy I think
she might be the one
oh awesome CIA
it's me
don't want to take my babies
[Music]
any other country man of your color
would not be wearing such fine clothes
one day the whole world will know me who
the hell is that
you still don't remember a thing I don't
remember any of it we don't want to go
down this road you're out of your bounds
Ahmed you're here to translate actually
I'm here to interpret we are the manual
life
is it
welcome back
feeling sad about going home though
he gets on that team everything changes
for him you need to turn down the raw
Rock what I'm excited
she broke up with me
he said like this
[Music]
it's tiring trying so hard all the time
doesn't it I don't know if I want to do
this just so that we're ready he's gone
let it be a lady
whoa